I'm going to start with a fair coin and
I'm going to flip it I am going to flip
it four times
flip it four times and the first
question I want to ask is what is the
probability that I get exactly exactly
one exactly one head or heads this is
one of those confusing things when
you're talking about the what side of
the coin I know I've been not doing this
consistently I'm tempted to say if
you're saying one it feels like you
should do the singular which would be
head but I've write it up on the I ran
up a little bit of it on the internet
and it seems like when you're talking
about coins you really should say one
heads which is a little bit it seems a
little bit difficult for me but I'll try
to go with that so what is the
probability of getting exactly one heads
and I put that in quotes to say that
well you know it's really we're just
talking about one head there but it's
called heads when you're dealing with
coins anyway I think you get what I'm
talking about and to think about this
let's think about how many different
possible ways we can get four flips of a
coin so we're going to have one flip
then another flip then another flip then
another flip and this first flip has two
possibilities it could be heads or tails
the second flip has two possibilities it
could be heads or tails the third flip
has two possibilities it could be heads
or tails and the fourth flip has two
possibilities it could be heads or tails
so you have two times two times two
times two which is equal to 16
possibilities 16 16 possible outcomes
when you flip when you flip a coin when
you flip a coin four times sixteen
possible outcomes and any one of the
possible outcomes would be one of
sixteen so if I wanted to say so if I
were to just say the probability and I'm
just going to not talk about this one
heads if I just take a just you know
maybe this thing that has three heads
right here this exact sequence of events
this is the first flip second flip third
flip fourth flip getting exactly this
this is exactly one out of a possible of
sixteen events now with that out of the
way let's think about how many
possibilities how many of those 16
possibilities involve getting exactly
one heads well we could list them you
could get your heads so this is equal to
the
ability the probability of the
probability of getting the heads in the
first flip plus the probability of
getting the heads in the second flip
plus the probability of getting the
heads in the third flip remember exactly
one heads we're not saying at least one
exactly one heads so probability in the
third flip and then or the possibility
that you get heads in the fourth flip
tails heads and tails and we know
already what the probability of each of
these things are there are sixteen
possible events and this is each of
these are one of those 16 possible
events so this this is going to be this
is going to be 1 over 16 1 over 16 1
over 16 and 1 over 16 and so we're
really saying the probability of getting
exactly one heads is the same thing as
the probability of getting heads in the
first flip or the probability of getting
heads or I should say the probability of
getting heads in the first flip or the
hit or heads in the second flip or heads
in the third flip or heads in the fourth
flip and we can add the probabilities of
these different things because they are
mutually exclusive
both any two of these things cannot
happen at the same time you have to pick
one of these scenarios and so we can add
the probabilities 1/16 plus 1/16 plus
1/16 plus 1/16 invested at 4 times we'll
assume that I did and so you would get 4
16s 4 16s which is equal to 1/4 fair
enough now let's ask a slightly more
interesting question let's ask ourselves
the probability probability of getting
exactly two heads exactly two heads
exactly two heads and there's there's a
couple of ways we can think about it one
is just in the traditional way and let's
just do we know the number of
possibilities and of those paths equally
likely possibilities and we can only use
this methodology because it's a fair
coin so how many of the of the total
possibilities have 2 heads of the total
of equally likely possibilities so we
know there are 16 equally likely
possibilities how many of those have 2
heads so I've actually ahead of time so
we save time I've drawn all of the 60
mean equally likely possibilities and
how many of these involve two heads well
let's see this one over here has two
heads this one over here has two heads
this one over here has two heads let's
see that's this one over here has two
heads and this one over here has two
heads and then this one over here has
two heads and I believe we are done
after that so if we count them one two
three four five six of the possibilities
have exactly two heads so six of the 16
equally likely possibilities have two
heads so we have a what is this a 3/8
chance of getting exactly two heads now
that's kind of what we've been doing in
the past but I want to do is think about
in a way so we wouldn't have to write
out all the possibilities and the reason
why that's useful is we're only dealing
with four flips now but if we were
dealing with 10 flips there's no way
that we could write out all the
possibilities like this so I really want
a different way of thinking about it and
the different way of thinking about it
is if we're saying exactly two heads you
can imagine we're having the four flips
flip one flip to flip three flip four so
these are the these are the these are
the flips or you could say the outcome
of the flips and if you're going to have
exactly two heads you could say well
look I'm going to have one head in one
of these positions and then one head and
the other position so how many if I'm
picking the first so I'm you know you
could say and I'm going to you know I
have kind of a heads one and I have a
heads two and I don't want you to think
that these are that these are somehow
the heads in the first flip are the
heads in the second flip what I'm saying
is we need two heads we need a total of
two heads in all of our flips and I'm
just giving one of the heads a name and
I'm giving the other head a name and
what we're going to see in a few seconds
is that we actually don't want to double
count we don't want to count the
situation we don't want to double count
this situation heads one heads to tails
tails and heads two heads one tails
tails for our purposes these are the
exact same outcomes so we don't want to
double count that and we're going to
we're going to have to account for that
but if we just think about it generally
how many different spots how many of
different flips can that first head show
up in well there's four different flips
that that first head could show up in so
there's four four possibilities for four
flips or four places that it could show
up in well if that first head takes up
one of these four places let's just say
that first head shows up on the first on
the third flip then how many different
places can that second head show up in
well if that first head is in one of the
four places and that second head can
only be in three different places so
that second head can only be I'm going
to picking a nice color here can only be
in three different can only be in three
different places and so you know it
could be in any one of these it could
maybe be right over there any one of
those three places and so when you think
about it in terms of the first and I
don't say the first head head one we
actually let me call it this way let me
call it head a and head B that way you
won't think that I'm talking about the
first flip or the second flip so this is
head a and this right over there is head
B so if you if you had a particular if I
mean these heads are identical we these
outcomes aren't different but the way we
talk talk about it right now
it looks like there's four places that
we could get this head in and there's
three places where we could get this
head in and so if you multiply all of
the different ways that you could get
before all of the different scenarios
where this is in four different places
and then this is in one of the three
leftover places you get twelve different
scenarios you get twelve different
scenarios different twelve different
scenarios but there would only be twelve
different scenarios if you viewed this
as being different than this and let me
rewrite it with our new so this is head
a this is head B this is head B this is
head a there would only be twelve
different scenarios if you viewed these
two things that's fundamentally
different but we don't we're actually
double counting because we can always
swap these two heads and have the exact
same outcome so what you want to do is
actually divide it by two so you want to
divide it by all of the different ways
that you can swap two different things
if we had three heads
you would think about all of the
different ways that you could swap three
different things if you had four heads
here would be all of the different ways
you could swap four different things so
you have there's twelve different
scenarios if you couldn't swap them but
you want to divide it by all of the
different ways that you can swap two
things so 12 divided by two is equal to
six six different scenarios different
fundamentally different scenarios
considering that you can swap them
scenarios if you assume that head a and
head B can be interchangeable that it's
it's it's a completely identical outcome
for us because it's really they're
really just heads so there's six
different scenarios and we know that
there's a total of we know that there's
a total of sixteen equally likely
scenarios so we could say that the
probability of exactly two heads is six
times six six scenarios and or we could
there's a couple of ways you could say
there are six scenarios that give us two
heads of a possible 16 or you could say
there are six possible scenarios and the
probability of each of those scenarios
is 1/16 but either way you'll get the
same answer